and the oscar for best documentary short
subject is awarded to
and the oscar goes to one survivor
remembers carrie antholos
wow um first and foremost
i would like to thank gerda weissman
klein and kurt klein for allowing us to
tell their story
my gratitude to sheila nevins for
deciding that this film should be made
and for lending her talent and passion
to its creation
to michael fuchs and the people of hbo
for sustaining an environment
where quality documentaries can be made
to michael barrenbaum ray farr and the
people of the holocaust museum
for their tremendous support to sandy
bradley larry silk
and sunburg and all of the countless
others who contributed to the film
to my mom my dad my brother bill and my
wife karen for their love and support
and finally in honor of the weissman and
klein families
i respectfully thank the academy
catty sheila sandy
michael my beloved husband and my family
i have been in a place for six
incredible years where winning
meant a crust of bread
and to live another day
since the blessed day of my liberation i
have asked the question
why am i here
i am no better
in my mind's eye i see those years and
days and those
who never lived to see
the magic of a boring
evening at home
on their behalf i wish to thank you for
honoring
their memory and you cannot do it in any
better way
than when you return to your homes
tonight
to realize that each of you
who know the joy of freedom
are winners thank you on
their behalf with all my heart
you